we begin this morning with the race to
rescue american diplomats and other key
personnel from the rapidly deteriorating
security conditions in kabul afghanistan
the first contingent of a marine
battalion arrived in the capital on
friday more marine and army units are
expected tomorrow this says the
taliban's stunning and lightning-fast
offensive seizes more territory
including kandahar and herat
afghanistan's second and third largest
cities a u.s defense official fears it
could be just a matter of days before
the hard-line islamists take control of
kabul a city with more than 4 million
people roxanna saberi begins our
coverage from the afghan capital roxanna
good morning
good morning afghanistan's president
ashraf ghani spoke publicly today for
the first time in days he's vowing to
keep fighting as the taliban keep
advancing toward this city
as the taliban take territory they also
gain
[Applause]
replenishing their ranks with taliban
prisoners they free along the way
and seizing the spoils of war left
behind by retreating afghan forces
trained by the u.s
pentagon spokesman john kirby we are
always worried about u.s equipment that
could fall into an adversary's hands
those adversaries now control more than
two-thirds of the country yesterday they
captured the capital of helmand province
where u.s troops once fought some of
their bloodiest battles
now the taliban are eyeing what's
essentially the afghan government's last
stand for now daily life here in the
capital kabul appears to be carrying on
more or less as usual but many people
here fear this way of life could soon
come to an end freedom equality and a
woman right all of these things are the
issues with everyone is concerned about
that they are killing women who were
born and raised here what about me
bonafsha rahimi says her family will
stay in afghanistan but as a woman who
studied on an american scholarship she
needs to flee
you're afraid of being killed
on the computer i'm afraid of being
killed like it's i'm like i'm like
totally sure that i will not survive
here
thousands of afghans are already
escaping many lining up at kabul's
airport this video appears to confirm
fears of the insurgent's brutality with
the taliban fighter counting 14 bodies
of men
executed for fighting back
and today heavy fighting reached the
doorsteps of kabul in the city of maidan
shah that's about 30 miles west of here
jeff
all right roxanna thank you the swift